MALE SPEAKER: It is
my sincere pleasure
to introduce Seth Casteel.
As I told him, I think
his title on the internet
goes as award winning
photographer and New York
Times best selling author.
So that's what I chose
to introduce him as.
But in all serious, Seth's
work is extremely well-known.
I think we've all seen it a lot,
books, magazines, newspapers,
everywhere.
And he's just coming out with a
new book, "Underwater Puppies,"
so no better time
to hear from him.
So without further
ado, I'm going
to let him tell you
guys about all of this.
Thank you.
SETH CASTEEL: Thank
you for the nice intro.
Well--
[APPLAUSE]
SETH CASTEEL:
--thanks, everybody
for having me come
out here today.
First time I've ever been
to the Google campus.
I'm real excited about it.
I had lunch over here,
met some really cool dogs.
I'm real happy to learn
that, obviously, lots
of dog people here, and lots
of dogs on campus and coming
to work.
I mean, I had that kind of
job too, so that's cool.
But it's always nice to
meet other folks that
could bring dogs to work,
so pretty cool deal.
So my name's Seth.
This is my latest project,
"Underwater Puppies."
this is important
for a lot of reasons.
We're going to get
into that in a minute.
But first I want
to talk about cats.
So a little bit about
me-- I'll probably
speak for about-- I don't
know-- I want to say 30 minutes.
If I see people sneaking
out or yawning or throwing
things at me, I
might shorten it.
But sometimes if you give
me a microphone, even
this microphone,
I'll have a tendency
to ramble on a little bit.
Also, while I'm
speaking, if you guys
have any questions
about anything--
it could be relevant or not--
feel free raise your hand
and ask me.
And I'll do my best to
answer your question.
How many dog people
are out there?
How many people like dogs?
Oh, good.
Because if you didn't
raise your hand,
I was going to ask you to leave.
How many people have dogs?
Oh, quite a few-- terrific.
Any good swimming
dogs out there?
Who has swimming dogs?
Cool, we'll talk later.
So I'm originally from
the state of Illinois.
I moved out to California to
go to film school in 1999.
I went to film school.
I thought I was going to be
a movie director or movie
producer, that kind of thing.
I got a job at Sony Pictures
Entertainment right out
of film school working
as an assistant
and then working in finance.
Having no experience in finance,
I found myself in a position
with some responsibility.
And then people always wonder,
jeez, what happened to Sony,
you know?
Maybe they hired people.
I can't believe that I'm saying
this and we're taping this,
but that's OK.
I'll also try not to
swear, because this
is going to be on the
internet someplace.
But anyways, I worked in finance
and somehow made the transition
over to advertising
for Columbia Pictures.
So I was working on advertising
campaigns for all Columbia's
big films, "Spiderman," "Angels
and Demons," The Da Vinci
Code," two James Bond films,
"Casino Royale," "Quantum
of Solace," and dozens
of other movies-- really,
really, fun job.
And because I worked at
Sony, I met these baby cats.
This is how it all began
for me back in 2007.
I had a friend who
will remain anonymous,
because maybe she'll see this.
But she'll know who she is.
Her name is blank,
a wonderful lady.
And she is an animal
welfare person.
She cares about animals more
than she cares about people.
And she is the
person that you go
to when you find a cat
that needs some help.
She won't tell you no.
Her heart is definitely bigger
than the logic of her mind.
And I applaud her for
that-- really sweet lady.
And I'll give you an example.
At one point when I
first met-- she was also
working at Sony with me--
she had about five cats.
And then time went by.
And then she had about 60 cats.
And I said, you know, hey, I
don't know a lot about cats.
But I feel like that's at
least five too many cats.
So anyway, she and
some of her friends
were taking care of
this cat colony living
on the Sony Pictures lot.
And they basically
just lived on the lot.
They would make sure the
cats were fed, taken care of.
I they had any new
additions to the cat colony,
they would trap the cats.
They would spay or neuter and
put them back into the studio
wild.
They had it pretty
good, the cats did.
I mean, I watched Brad Pitt
pet some cats out there
at one point.
And cats are just
roaming around.
And of course, it was
so good for the cats.
Life was good.
The cats got on the phone,
they called all their friends.
And everybody was
just coming in.
So of course, what happens?
You get baby cats.
So my friend found these cats.
And she said, oh, no, Seth.
There's more cats.
And I'm thinking, oh, my gosh.
So I was getting into
photography a little bit
at the time.
I had just got a Canon Rebel
XT and a Sigma 24 to 70 lens.
Not knowing a whole lot
about photography or cats,
I just said, you know what?
Why don't we use this Sony email
network that we have set up.
We can just blast out an
email to everybody at Sony.
We'll sneak these kittens
in to an executive's office
down the way.
We'll take some
pictures of them.
And we'll put them out there
in the Sony email network.
Now, you're not really
supposed to use the network
for that kind of thing.
But I'm like, well, what
are they going to do?
Are they going to
fire us for trying
to help homeless kittens.
I'm like, that's a great
PR line right there.
Sony fires employees for
helping homeless kittens.
So anyways, that's what we did.
We took these snapshots.
My favorite is right here,
a little claw on the couch,
just leaving a little mark here.
But we took these shots,
put them out on the network.
And 24 hours later, all
the kittens were adopted.
That's pretty cool.
So then a couple weeks
later, guess what?
More baby cats, the
fire engine kittens.
We found these kittens in a
fire engine trying to stay warm.
And they were literally in a
fire engine near the engine.
And they were just trying
to stay warm in there.
So we did it again,
took some more pictures.
They all got adopted.
And I'm like, wow,
this is pretty cool.
So I started volunteering at
the West LA Animal Shelter.
I said, do you guys need
help with photography?
You know, I've been
photographing these little baby
cats, and they got adopted.
Do you need any help?
And they said, yeah, come on in.
So I started volunteering to
take better adoption photos
to help find specific homes for
dogs and cats at the shelter.
And that was back in 2007.
So I'll do a slideshow,
just kind of the process
and how this all kind
of came to be for me.
And these are taken over
the last several years
in different shelters
around the country.
But I'm going to show you
typical intake shots and then
the more positive
adoption photo.
So this is sort of
a typical intake
shot that you're going to find.
As of a few years ago at an
animal shelter, not exactly
a great marketing tool for
little Gloria here, you know?
You see this and
generally, you're
going to be a little
bit terrified.
Some people would argue, oh,
there's a sympathy card here.
You're concerned, so you're
going to go into the rescue
and you're going to save Gloria.
And that's true a tiny bit.
But mostly what happens
is people are afraid.
People see this, and they think,
I could never go in there.
What am I going to see?
What kind of experience
am I going to have?
I could never be
my kids in there.
And it turns people off.
And I'm happy to say this even
though it's being recorded.
There's a campaign out there
you may have seen on TV.
And the shoutout's
to Sarah McLachlan.
Images, Sarah
McLachlan music-- has
anybody seen the commercials?
AUDIENCE: I've seen the
"South Park" version.
SETH CASTEEL: OK.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: And how many
people turn the channel,
change the channel
when they see that?
It's negative, right?
It's a negative thing.
And people just think, oh--
they hear the music now.
Any time that song comes on,
you're just like, oh, my god.
Now, in all fairness,
it is the ASPCA.
I'm happy to talk about them.
Their friends of mine.
I love what they do.
They're making a huge
difference overall.
But I have to argue, is that
campaign really effective?
Now, it's not an
adoption campaign.
It's a fundraising campaign.
It's been extremely
successful for the ASPCA.
But I argue-- and I'm still
looking for my meeting
with the president of the ASPCA.
So ASPCA, if you're out
there on camera, call me.
Let's have a meeting.
And hopefully,
it'll be productive
and I can help you guys out.
But I have to
argue, at what cost
is that campaign causing
the entire effort?
So yeah, they're raising
money, but they're
scaring people away.
So many people see
the commercials
and they're terrified.
They won't go into the shelter.
And it's done a lot
of damage, I think,
for the image of
rescue and adoption.
So the point of
doing this is-- even
though this is
stretched out, this
is kind of against
that campaign.
So this is trying
to inspire people
to be a part of the cause,
inspire people to come in
and say hello,
embrace the animal
shelter or your local
rescue, and volunteer, adopt
a new little friend, rather
than change the channel.
You know what I mean?
So this is kind of
what we're doing?
And these are just-- I'll do a
little slideshow here and kind
of show you what we're up to.
Olive.
You know, when these dogs
and cats come into the animal
shelter-- I want you
to look at Chubbs.
And they look so
funny because they're
stressed out here a little bit.
So when they come
in, they're coming in
at all hours of the day,
all hours of the night,
from a variety of circumstances,
most of which are not positive.
And you can only imagine
what Ruben's thinking here.
Like, what is
going on right now?
So I do like the bandanna.
I think that's a
plus, but overall,
just not a very productive
marketing shot for Ruben here.
And this is in
Chicago, taken in 2011.
And this is probably
sometime in the evening.
You know, you have a lead, which
is a chain, which is terrible.
You have the ominous boots
and the legs over here.
And this is just not
a really good shot.
But unfortunately, you
know, when Ruben comes in,
an ID shot's taken.
So it's basically just
to keep track who's who.
And the ID shots
oftentimes are what
is used to find a
home for that pet.
It's just not the
best opportunity
at that time to take a picture.
And it's of no fault
of the shelter staff,
most of these people.
So public shelters
have really no money.
They always struggle
to find support.
They have not enough staff.
They have not
enough of anything.
So they're just
struggling to try
to do the best
they possibly can.
They don't have proper
photography equipment.
So this is kind of what
you're going to get.
So I can't really
blame the people.
It's just the situation.
Here we go.
I think this is better.
But what we're finding
is people are actually
printing these images out.
They see them online.
They bring them in.
And they want to meet Ruben.
Or they want to meet this
little Min Pin right here.
He's kind of funny.
It cracks me up that
it's stretched out.
But it's funny
Baily-- this is also in Chicago.
And this is the real
intake shot for Bailey.
This is probably some
time back in 2010 or '11.
Again, you wouldn't
really even know
what Baily looks like here.
And you have this.
I think it looks a
little better anyways.
Wilma-- this is also in Chicago.
And when I started volunteering
in Chicago-- so basically,
I went from West
LA the South LA.
I started traveling around
to different cities,
just volunteering at animal
shelters all over the place.
And then I started my own
charity called Second Chance
Photos, just teaching
workshops to people
who were interested about how
to take better adoption photos.
So that's kind of what
you're seeing here.
These are taken in cities
all over the country.
I then started
teaching workshops
in other countries, in
Europe and also in Australia
and learn a lot about what
is effective for these guys.
Wilma-- I mean, I think this is
just night and day right here.
I mean, look at the
difference here.
All these dogs got adopted,
which is pretty cool.
And you wouldn't
really even know
what Black looks like here.
There he is.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: Now, this is
a little smoke and mirrors,
because one of my
secrets that I'll do
is that if the dog is
allowed to have treat,
it is behaving a
little bit, then
I'll let the dog chew a treat
while I'm taking the picture.
And you're seeing that here.
It also works good for people.
This guy's having a snack
back here right now.
You can take a shot of him.
It'd probably be pretty good.
So then kind of fast forward--
so I was working at Sony.
I went over to Disney.
Oh, this is interesting,
because this
is going to be available
for people to download.
I got fired from Disney Studios.
I did get fired.
I walked in, got fired
for no good reason.
However, I still love Disney.
I love Disney.
I always have.
I love the message.
It was a dream to go work
for Walt Disney Studios.
Walt Disney has always
been one of my heroes.
And I still love the company.
I came in one day.
I'd been working 90, 100 hours
a week, working my tail off.
I didn't get laid off.
I got fired for reasons
completely beyond my control
that I didn't think were fair.
But I decided that I would
rather work with dogs and cats.
So I walked in one day
and they said, you know,
you're out of here.
And I didn't burn a bridge.
But I decided to spend my
time with dogs and cats.
I'd already been developing
my craft as a photographer.
I'd been doing the
volunteer thing.
I'd been doing a little bit
of commissions on the weekend.
People would say, can I hire
you to photograph my dog?
So basically, when that
fateful day happened in 2009
at Disney Studios, it was
ultimately a good day for me.
I mean, that changed my life.
If that didn't happen,
I would have never
been doing any of
these projects.
And I would still-- I don't
know what I would be doing.
who knows?
But so I really am
glad that happened.
At the time, it seemed
kind of dramatic.
But it did give
me the opportunity
to go pursue what I really love.
And that's working with animals.
So I went off, did
that full time.
Things weren't going that well.
I was struggling to find enough
work to really make ends meet,
pay for my rent, pay for the
car, pay for health insurance
now, pay for a hot date
every once in awhile.
That was adding up.
So I couldn't really afford
living in Los Angeles.
And I had kind of
a ticking clock.
I mean, I was going to run out.
I had about $50,000 in debt
already on the credit card.
My cash flow was very limited.
My parents were like, oh,
how's it going out there?
I'm like, it's going great.
They didn't know.
So I struck a deal with
a company called Groupon.
Everybody know Groupon?
I struck a deal with Groupon.
I was pretty excited about that.
They approached me to do a deal
for a pet photography shoot.
Now, it seemed also at
the time that Groupon
was approaching
everybody to do anything.
So if you would do a
deal with Groupon--
so I guess it wasn't
that flattering.
But I just thought,
you know what?
I got to stay busy.
I got to find opportunities.
I got to work.
I want to just work on my craft.
And I thought, let's do it.
For $59, you could hire me.
I would come out to your home
or location of your choosing
to do a 30-minute photo shoot.
You also get two 8 by 10 prints.
And I made about $29
out of that deal.
So I made about half, a
little less than half.
So when I was-- it was
supposed to be a 10 mile
radius of my home is where
the shots could take place.
No, it was more like 150 miles.
So people were booking
me in Santa Barbara.
People were booking
me in San Diego.
So I was-- I don't know.
I mean, I was like,
well, I got to do it.
So I was driving
all over the place.
And I was doing the math,
trying to be a business owner,
looking at the math of it.
And I'm like, well,
I'm definitely
not making any money.
How much am I loosing?
Because when you're driving to
Santa Barbara and back, I mean,
just do the math
on the gas alone.
I mean, you're not
coming out ahead for $29.
That's for sure.
A 30-minute shoot would extend
to an hour, an hour and a half,
two hours, sometimes
even longer,
and then all the
time I'm spending
on editing and everything else.
So it was really an epic
fail for me to do the Groupon
shoot, except for this
little character right here.
He's the knight
in shining armor.
This is Buster the Cavalier
King Charles Spaniel.
I show up at his house in
2010 at a Groupon photo shoot.
And he decided he would rather
be in the pool than on land.
This is a shot.
I did this interview
with NBC Nightly News
with Brian Williams
a couple weeks ago.
And they asked me, do you
have any original shots
of Buster from when
you first met him?
So I looked back at
an old hard drive.
I haven't seen
these in years now.
I just haven't thought about it.
And I came across these.
This is now one of my favorite
shots I think I've ever taken.
Because this is right before
everything began for me.
I didn't know it at the time.
You can already
see he's wet here.
So he's already been
in probably once.
And now he's
looking at us again,
saying-- in the
background, I have
Jane, who's Buster's human.
You'd better not do that.
And he's thinking, oh,
yeah, I'm going in.
So of course he went
in over and over again.
She wasn't happy
about it, because she
wanted some beautiful
dry land shots of Buster
with this hair
blowing in the breeze.
And I said, wait a second.
Maybe there's something to this.
I left, bought the little point
and shoot underwater camera.
It was a Sony, I think a TX5.
I came back and started
doing these kind of shots,
knowing really nothing about
underwater photography,
nothing about this camera.
I wasn't even sure if
I was taking pictures.
It was kind of confusing.
But you can see him
in the background.
And then you have-- this
is kind of the transition.
He's going in.
And then you have that.
[LAUGHTER]
And so this is the very
first underwater dog shot
that I took.
And this is back in 2010.
I didn't know I had this.
I got home and saw it was
just like, wait a second.
This is unbelievable.
I was so excited about it.
So of course, I sent this
to Jane, my friend Jane.
I said, oh, my god, Jane.
You know, you have to see what
Buster looks like underwater.
And she said, yeah, yeah.
But we didn't get the
dry shots, you know.
You've got to come back
down here and get this.
So I went back down.
I drove back down because
we didn't get the dry shots,
did the drive shots.
AUDIENCE: For $29.
SETH CASTEEL: Yeah,
back and forth.
Who knows how much money I
lost initially on that shoot.
But as it turns out, it
was a good idea anyway.
So we went back, did this.
And then I was just
getting really curious
about the underwater thing.
So I started doing
more shots of Buster,
playing around different
types of underwater camera
gear, underwater camera bags.
I tried out different
types of casings.
I rented a dive housing one
time for $500 for the weekend,
and it broke.
Oh, it was tough.
But I was interested in learning
about underwater photography
and also just fascinated with
dogs and their connection
to the water.
So I was just doing these,
various types of lighting,
really no idea what I'm doing.
But Buster here, he kind of
helped me figured it all out.
Did this, which is now a tattoo
on my arm, which you see.
Oh, there's me underwater here.
But you have this picture now is
actually right here on my arm.
Look how noble
Buster looks here.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: He's just
so proud, you know?
But yeah, so this
shot is actually
one of my favorite shots.
And this is a picture I did
with an underwater camera bag,
as it turns out.
I put it on a hard drive.
I mean, I was taking all kinds
of pictures, didn't really know
what I was looking for.
I put it on a hard drive,
didn't even realize
I had this shot until
about a year later.
I went back through
and found it.
And now it's on my arm forever.
People say, wow, you have
somebody else's dog tattooed
on your arm.
But this is the guy that
changed my life forever.
And if I could buy
him a beer, I would.
But he has unlimited
dog treats from me
for the rest of eternity.
But here's a little
selfie we did.
I don't know who got
the ball on this take.
I look like I might have got.
Or I might have got part of
his mouth in my foot too.
It's hard to say.
OK, there's us.
And then after working
with Buster, I was like,
who else likes to swim?
As it turns out, a lot
of dogs like to swim.
And they have a
connection with the water
that goes back
almost 20,000 years.
So I started working with
all these guys, all kinds
of different types
of dogs, and just
doing fun photo
shoots just for fun,
not making any money on it.
| invested the last
few thousand dollars
I had available on a credit
card in a surf housing, which
is an underwater housing
designed for surf photographers
and surfers.
So I bought this.
It's from SPL Water Housings.
And mostly I bought it
because it was more affordable
than a dive housing.
And I liked that it
was bright yellow.
I thought that could
come into play.
And I like that I didn't have
to buy additional lighting.
I could just put my
flash on top of it.
So I created the original series
with this housing and a Canon
70 with a Tokina 10
to 17 fisheye lens
and made these shots
really, just for fun.
See all these clowns and
all kinds of different dogs.
This is a Cocker Spaniel here.
This is a Jack Russell terrier.
And this shot ended up in
"National Geographic Magazine,"
"Visions of Earth"
back in August of 2012.
That was a dream come
true right there.
This shot right
here, this was a shot
that really took my
photography from nobody
knew about me to everybody
knows about "Underwater Dogs."
This happened on
February 9, of 2012.
And I have a couple
people to thank
including reddit and Google.
So thanks, Google.
A lot of people don't know that.
But this image became
a top thread on reddit.
And then it moved
through Google+.
It moved through all kinds
of different social media
platforms.
We tried to track exactly
what all-- and it was just
a frenzy of action.
But it happened overnight.
And then no one exactly knows
how many tens of millions
of people saw the
shots overnight.
But it was out of control.
My website was crashed.
My website was on
a shared server
with GoDaddy with
limited bandwidth.
And it was just down.
But I like to think what you
can't have, you want more.
So people were trying
to get on my site.
Oh, man, I can't
get on the site.
So it's a funny little game.
But yeah, so this was the
shot that kind of went viral
on February 9 of-- well,
it didn't kind of go viral.
It went viral.
I had no idea that
could even happen.
And my life has never
been the same since then.
So out of control-- here's the
first book, "Underwater Dogs."
So basically, when the images
went viral, one went viral.
Then people started picking
up the rest of them.
And it just made a whole round.
And I'm talking
about a global round.
I mean, everywhere,
all over the place.
The inquiries I
was getting-- I was
getting 10,000 emails a day.
I don't know how that happened.
I mean, I was tracking traffic
on my website at 150,000.
And my website was crashed
most the time, you know?
And I was still getting
that many emails.
I didn't have an assistant.
I was trying to figure out
which emails were important.
The next morning, I was on the
phone with CNN World Report.
On the other line was
Good Morning America.
And I was trying to figure
out who was more important.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: So I could get
into this for a little while.
But basically, as
a photographer,
you always hope to make a
living maybe as a photographer.
I mean, I certainly was
trying to make a living.
That was my career.
And I'm like, wow, I've
been handed an opportunity.
I've got to seize
the moment here.
You know, I found
my underwater dog.
Now I've had this opportunity.
Seize the moment.
Make the most of it.
And so I just went after it.
I did all kinds of interviews.
I fielded inquiries
from literary agents,
knowing nothing
about publishing.
I selected a book agent named
Michelle Tessler based out
of New York.
I didn't know if that
was the right choice.
She liked dogs.
I like dogs.
So we teamed up,
made a book proposal.
The book went to auction.
All the major publishers and
a bunch of other publishers
bid on the rights
to sell the book.
I'm on the phone one
day with Random House
and Simon Schuster and
HarperCollins a Chronicle.
And I really don't even
know what was going on.
It was a really good
problem to have.
But everybody bid on the book.
It went to three rounds.
Little Brown, Random
House, and Simon Schuster
were the final three bidders.
And I ended up
choosing Little Brown
and turning down Random House.
I'm sorry, Random House.
I like you.
But it just didn't work out.
Little Brown's been wonderful.
I'm really happy
to work with them.
They're also big dog people.
So we went out, shot
the book in 60 days
all around the country, 300
dogs, published the book
October, 2012.
The initial print run
was extremely limited.
The book was sold out for almost
a month around the holidays.
Even though it was one of
a Oprah's favorite books
of the year, you couldn't
buy it almost anywhere.
But it was still a "New
York Times" best seller
for 11 weeks, the
bestselling photographer book
of the year, one of the
bestselling books ever made
with over a half a million
copies in print right now,
13 editions around the world.
And it's just dogs jumping
into swimming pools.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: Pretty crazy.
But anyways, it was
just phenomenal for me.
You know, I have to
pinch myself every day
because of what's happened.
So we made a kids book too.
Some of the adults thought the
images were too primal or too
scary for the kids, which was
weird, because all the kids I
was hanging out
with, they thought
the shots were hilarious.
Or we made a kids
book for adults
and included a free
poster for them.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: There's
some fun rhymes in here.
I'm not much of a writer.
I'm technically an author.
But I'm not much of a writer.
I wouldn't consider
myself a very good writer.
But I did get to write
some fun rhymes in here.
Little Brown said,
hey, you know,
we're going to hire
someone to write your book.
I'm like, what?
I can't do it?
So I wrote some fun rhymes.
I don't know if they're good.
But I think they're appropriate.
And that was a lot of fun.
Also, some of the
kids were ripping
the pages out of the books,
they were so excited,
apparently, or
they're just kids.
So we made board books.
Those were published
a few months back.
And so we have
colors and numbers.
If you're learning
to count to 10,
I recommend the
book on the right.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: Puppies-- after
"Underwater Dogs" happened,
we thought, all right,
what's going to happen next?
Underwater cats-- the natural--
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: The
natural choice.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: I bought the
website, underwatercats.com.
If you go there, you will find
approximately zero pictures.
But I thought one day, if
the world's upside down,
dogs are cats and cats
are dogs, at least
I'll be ready for that.
I have been swimming
with some cats.
They choose to get in.
Turkish Vans, Maine
Coons, Bangles,
some other exotic mixes
do you have a history
with the water and
appreciation for the water.
And they get in and swim.
Now, it's not every cat
within those breeds.
But certainly you will find
some swimming cats out there,
but not diving in and
not the same relationship
that we find with dogs.
So that book's on
hold indefinitely.
Now, I have been swimming
with some exotic cats.
I've been in the water with
tigers as well as bobcats.
And you could make a series.
And I've done some shots.
You could make a
series about that.
I don't think you
could do a full book.
And it's also not domestic cats.
So most of us wouldn't
have a relationship
with a tiger or a bobcat.
But many of us, of course,
do have relationships
with domestic cats,
so maybe one day.
Puppies-- in "Underwater
Dogs," you'll
find a couple of puppies,
one of which is 12 weeks.
The other is six months.
I thought, well, could I make
a whole book with puppies?
It would be fun.
But I don't know if I can.
So I started just
exploring the idea
of working with puppies to find
out if it was even possible
and how I felt about it.
And what I found was not
only could I make it,
but it needed to be made for
two very important reasons.
And the first is the
most critical reason.
It's water safety for pets.
So every year, it's estimated
between 7 and 10,000 dogs
drown in swimming pools
in the United States.
That's a lot of dogs.
Now, there's millions of dogs.
But 7 to 10,000,
that's a lot of dogs.
It's a shocking number.
And I hate to say that.
This is a very joyful project.
But the sense of urgency
about water safety
is very, very high.
And it's not because people
don't like their dogs.
You know, people
just don't understand
the dangers of a
swimming pool, especially
in states like California,
Arizona, Texas, Florida.
I mean, in neighborhoods,
you'll find pools
at every single home.
And pools are on the rise,
more and more pools every year.
The weather seems to be
getting hotter everywhere.
More and more pools
are happening,
more and more danger.
Now, pools can be a lot
of fun for all of us.
But they're also a
major, major danger
for pets and human
children as well.
But people don't
think about that.
I ask folks.
I'm like, would you leave
your 18-month-old human baby
unattended in your
backyard next to your pool
while your away at work?
No, I would never do that.
But the same people would
potentially leave their dog
there, who's never
been in the pool before
and has no proper experience
in understanding what it is
or how to get out.
So all puppies know
how to swim when
they're three or four weeks old.
You put them into the water,
or even above the water,
and they start to
check things out.
It's an instinct.
It's hardwired in.
They know how to do it.
It's the doggy paddle.
And they start off slow.
And then they'll go faster.
And you put them in.
Most of them are
buoyant little things.
And they'll just--
and they're terrific.
But they need to practice.
They need to practice.
They need to build confidence.
And most importantly,
they need to understand
how to get out of
a swimming pool.
And that's the number one thing.
That's the number
one thing that we
have to make sure we get across.
Because you're dog
falls into the pool.
They're going to make
an effort to swim.
They're going to make an
effort to try to get out.
But it's not a natural body of
water, so there's a disconnect.
If you're at a lake, if
you're in a stream, a river,
the ocean, anything
that's natural,
chances are you're going to
have multiple options of how
to get out, because
there's going
to be some kind of a natural
gradient or natural way
to find yourself out.
A lot of pools these
days still just
have ladders or will just have
one exit, which is stairs.
And it may not be
accommodating at all for a dog.
Most dogs that drown drown
two feet away from the exit.
They just swim around
circles and they don't know.
It's terrible.
They're not great climbers.
So they can't pull
themselves out.
It happens all the time.
It's not because people are--
they're not deliberately
trying to set their
pet up for disaster.
But it's happening.
So there's a lot of
other things going on
with swimming pools
in terms of safety,
limiting access, fences,
alarms, a lot of things
that should be happening.
But also, preparing
your pet to be safe
is the number one thing.
That number should not
be between 7 and 10,000.
I mean, that's just
ridiculous, if you ask me.
So that's what
this book promotes.
It's promoting water
safety for pets.
You know, if I can improve
that number even just
a little bit and I sell no
books, that's fine with me,
you know?
I just want to get
the message out there.
So that's the number one thing.
The number two thing
is rescue and adoption.
That's how I got started.
Most of the puppies you'll
find in here are rescue puppies
and have since been adopted.
I finished the book
about a year ago.
And just as a reminder
to folks that you
can find wonderful pets at
your local animal shelter.
And I think so many people
just don't realize that.
I was talking to a friend
of mine pretty recently.
And he has a puppy enrolled
in a puppy training class.
And it's the only rescue puppy
out of 12 or 13 in there.
And you're thinking,
why is that?
You know, why is it happening?
I don't criticize
people for buying dogs,
but I do suggest to people
to consider rescuing a pet
because I think it's
a terrific option.
Most people just
don't understand
you can get a great,
great dog, a great cat.
They're not broken, you know?
They're not having problems.
They are terrific pets.
You just got to go and do it.
That's it.
And you could find
pure bred dogs.
You can find mixed breed dogs.
You can find puppies.
I mean, I've seen it all.
And I will tell you, no
matter what you want to find,
you can find it through
a shelter or rescue.
It might take you a couple extra
minutes to do the research,
but you can find it.
So I thought it was
cool to kind of feature
some of these guys as my little
rescue puppy ambassadors.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: This
is in Chicago.
So I worked with
about 1,500 puppies
on this project, mostly
just as a swim teacher,
and occasionally
as a photographer.
Most the poppies came out.
They got initial lessons to
understand their physicality
in the water,
buoyancy, and start
to condition them
to look for the exit
and find their way out.
Out of 1,500, you'll find just
72 in the book, 105 pictures.
Most of the puppies didn't
get pictures at all.
They just swim A to B a
couple times and they go home.
Some of the puppies
obviously decided
that they do enjoy
themselves here.
And they were very
curious and became playful
and would jump in, either at
me, with me, or chase toys.
So those are the puppies
you'll find in the book.
And it was kind of my job
once I figured out, OK,
who's dominating right now?
Who's ready to play?
And then I'd just grab
my camera do some shots.
But there were some
photo shoot events.
In Chicago, I had one.
We had 30 puppies come out.
Zero pictures in the
book out of 30 puppies.
I spent all day, flew in.
My gear didn't arrive.
I had to have my backup gear
flown in overnight for $400.
Weeks of planning, not
a single book shot.
Everybody got a lesson.
But then this particular day,
I mean, we had this shot.
We had this shot.
We probably had 15 book shots.
And so you never really know
when it's going to happen.
So it's kind of cool.
But this was maybe going
to be the book cover.
But we thought maybe
it's a little too sassy
to be the book cover.
This is Ginger,
all grown up now.
I saw her the other day.
She's a wonderful
swimmer, and looks
almost the same--
same markings--
just a little bit older.
This is Raleigh.
This is in Tucson, Arizona.
Quick note about this-- so
this is an outdoor pool.
I work with outdoor pools
and indoor pools for this.
Water temperature
was very important.
Between 80 and 92
degrees is where
I like to have the water for
the puppies and for myself,
but mostly for the puppies.
We wouldn't teach
our human children
to swim in 40 degree water.
I hope not.
So these guys, you want to
make them feel comfortable.
You don't want to shock
them by putting them
in water that's too cold.
This water actually
is in Tucson.
And I knew it was cold
at night in Tucson.
So I called the pool owner.
And I'm like, hey, man.
It's been getting
kind of cold there.
How's the water?
He's like, it's kind of cold.
Do you have a heater?
Yeah.
Turn it on.
OK.
He turns on the heater.
I arrive the next day.
It's 100 degrees out.
The heaters still on and the
bubble tarp is on top of it.
We peel it back-- 107 degrees.
I know.
So we went to the refrigerator.
We got a bunch ice cubes,
we're throwing them in.
You got to try something.
So we got it down to 102 by
the time the puppies arrived.
And we had the opposite problem.
The puppied could only be
in for a couple minutes,
because it's just
too hot for them.
But we were able to get a
couple of really cool shots.
These are my little terriers.
This kind of thing
doesn't happen very often.
When they jump in, some of the
puppies are getting playful.
And learn about it.
They jump in.
And when they jump
in together, I mean,
that's the kind of thing
that doesn't happen often.
So I'm really happy that
these two little Chicago
puppies are in the book.
They're little terriers
named Pringles and Pickme.
You'll also notice the
lights behind here.
You can see these lights.
These are not pool lights.
These are what's called
off-board strobes.
Any photographers in here?
I'm the only guy.
Well, it's not super exciting.
But I'll just kind of
tell you how it goes down.
So I'm using a dive housing now
by Ikelite, Ikelite Underwater
Systems.
So it's basically
a case designed
for going really
deep, 200 feet deep.
I'm only underwater here
about two feet or so.
And I'm using two strobes.
They're called DS161's.
One here, one here-- and
I can move them around.
I can change the
intensity of the strobe.
I'm also dropping in what's
called off-board strobes.
They're not connected
to the camera.
They have a funny little device
on them called an EV manual
controller.
It's like an eyeball.
What happens is it looks for
a change in ambient light.
So when I drop this down
at the bottom of the pool,
when I fire off my flashes,
this flash goes off.
I can drop one of
those, two of those.
It also creates
little catch lights
in the top right of the image.
That's caused by
the off-bard strobe.
It just improves the images,
I think, technically.
And we can see the dogs
a little bit better.
But it's fun.
Sometimes I drop none in.
Sometimes I drop 1, 10.
It's about $1,700 apiece.
So sometimes you're in the pool.
You're thinking, I've got
about $32,000 in here.
I didn't have
insurance on the gear.
But everything's fine.
But this is little
Eva the Beagle.
Here's what she looks like now.
Fun, huh?
All grown up, same markings.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SETH CASTEEL: Yeah, I just
saw this dog the other day.
And I was like, wow.
So I just had this
in here today,
because they sent
me these pictures.
And it's crazy.
I mean, here, she's
about six weeks.
And here, she's about
a year and six weeks.
Kind of fun, huh?
This is Corey.
This is also in Tucson in
water that's about 80 degrees.
I just really like how
vivid this shot is.
and in the moment, he
looks pretty happy.
There were six of these
little cattle dog mix puppies,
all rescues in Tucson.
This is another one, Zelda.
This is my favorite shot in the
book-- and I'll tell you why--
not because it's the
best technically.
It's not even underwater.
It's an over-under shot.
The reason why I like it--
so Zelda and Corey, brother
and sister.
Zelda's a special needs puppy,
needs some additional TLC.
The people that we're looking
after Zelda were saying,
she's not ready for
swimming, you know?
She's not ready.
And I was thinking,
wait a minute.
Zelda's allowed to be
around swimming pools.
She's going to be adopted
by someone here in Arizona
and probably live at a place
where there's a swimming pool.
She needs a lesson.
They said, no, no, no, no.
That's not going to work.
So little Zelda here watched
me, Corey, and the other four
do the swim lessons
for about a half hour.
All of a sudden, I hear splash.
Zelda jumped in on her
own, jumped on her own.
And she swam right to the exit.
And it's a big pool.
She swam right to the exit.
I wasn't even over there.
But she had watched us.
And she had watched all
of her little friends
learn how to get out.
And she learned how to get out.
And that was my proudest
moment during the whole book.
And that's what it's all about.
So this little puppy
is safer for that.
So I had to put her in there.
I mean, she didn't
jump in 100 times.
But she watched and she learned.
She did it on her own.
And I'm like, that's
what I'm talking about.
I was just so proud.
This is kind of another
sassy shot, Monte.
This is in New York.
City there's a pool
for dogs in the city
of New York in Manhattan
called Water for Dogs.
And it's mostly a
hydrotherapy pool.
So they're rehabilitating
dogs from injury
or as a sort of
recovery from surgery.
Hydrotherapy is an
incredible thing
that is improving the quality
of life for thousands of dogs
here in the States and
all around the world.
And it's wonderful that more
and more pools are popping up.
And dogs can have a much
higher quality of life
and can extend their lives
by years because of it.
So that's what this
pool was designed for.
Also, apparently, it's designed
for underwater puppy photo
shoots.
So I went in here to
have a few New York dogs.
I thought this kind of
looks like the movie
"The Ring" a little bit.
[LAUGHTER]
But just real sassy.
I mean, I love--
with underwater dog,
you see such a
range of emotions.
This dog is sleeping right here.
I got to be more entertaining.
[LAUGHING]
SETH CASTEEL: You see
such a range of emotions.
I feel like dogs have
a very similar range
of emotions to human beings.
And that's why we connect
with them so much.
And that's why we can also
appreciate these images.
Because maybe in each picture
we see a little bit of too.
So I like to put that in there.
Also, point it out-- this is a
hairy hairless Chinese crested.
And I think it was 10 weeks
or 11 weeks, named Scooter.
It also goes to
show you not just
the labs and golden
retrievers like to swim.
So many people say that to me.
Oh, it's just labs a
golden retrievers, right?
I meet labs and
golden retrievers
all the time that don't like to
swim or are not good swimmers.
And it's because of
whatever their history is.
Now, labs and
goldens, they might
have more of a history in
general with the water.
But you'll still find labs
and goldens that or not
into it or that are
not great swimmers
because they haven't had
the right experience.
And then you meet
these little clowns.
And they're just dominating.
I mean, you got to remember too,
most dog breeds, pretty much
all dog breeds,
they're almost exactly
identical with they're genetics.
It's almost exact,
with minor differences.
The history's the same.
They're all coming from wolves.
And obviously, there's a
lot of different things
that have happened along
the way over 20,000 years.
But most dog breeds
are fairly new.
And they're all pretty much
related, very closely related.
So the history's
almost the same.
So even though
some of these dogs
may have forgotten their
connection with the water,
they can remember it.
And it comes back to them.
All the time, I meet dogs
who have never been around
water or just have a fear of it.
But with the right
experience, and once
they can turn a curiosity into
confidence, they can dominate.
I've met dogs who have
never been swimming.
And they come with
me in the pool
and they dive down six
feet and they have a blast.
So that happens.
But I do have a poodle of my
own, a little poodle mix named
Nala who you will
not find in the book,
except for in my author photo.
She's a great swimmer.
She'll get in the creek and
look around a little bit.
But she doesn't have
a retrieve drive.
And it's just her
number one hobby.
So my next book is actually
called, "Nala on the Couch."
And it's going to be 2000 pages.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: Here's
my little boxer.
This is Prince, eight weeks old,
looks like an Olympic swimmer,
I think-- excellent form.
This is in Portland, Maine.
These are my labs.
These guys are my stars.
They started swimming
at six weeks of age.
And these guys are being kind
of prepped to be DockDogs.
Anybody familiar with DockDogs?
So DockDogs is a competition
for dogs and their humans.
It's all about
jumping off a platform
to see how far they
can go into the pool
and how high they can go.
And it's a lot of fun.
The dogs go crazy for it.
I mean, it's a blast.
Some of the people are kind
of interesting, you know?
You get the stage moms
that are like it's
like they're little
ballerinas or something
like that or little actresses.
But the dogs do love it.
They think it's hilarious.
And it's a very positive thing.
So these guys are
going to be DockDogs.
At six weeks they
started swimming.
By nine weeks, they go
would show at the pool
and whine at the gate,
because they wanted to get in.
That's how much they liked it.
I met them at 10
weeks, 10 and 1/2.
It was a no-brainer.
They hadn't really
been underwater yet.
But you know,
everything was in line.
So I got to work with
all three of them, Reese
and Grits and Jack.
You'll find all
three in the book.
There they are with
the puppy teeth.
But even at 11 weeks, they start
to look a little bit older.
But the puppy teeth
tell it all for sure.
Here's these two.
I wanted to work with
all three underwater.
I thought, wouldn't that be
something if we could do that?
But even though they live
with different people--
they all live in
Fort Myers, Florida.
They each live in
their respective home.
But they spend a lot
of time together.
When that happens,
they're going to come
across a hierarchy, who's the
boss and who's not the boss.
It's going to happen.
Anybody out there
have two dogs or more?
Yeah, I mean, if you have two
dogs spending time together,
you'll figure out
who is the boss.
And this guy right here
can tell you that too.
But that's how it goes down.
And even if dogs are spending
a lot of time together,
they will establish a hierarchy.
These puppies started to
establish a hierarchy.
Jack, who you don't
see in this picture,
is somewhere in the background,
looking for another toy.
But he would not
compete with these two.
He would not go under with them.
These two were still
trying to duke it out.
Who is the boss, you know?
So they would compete
with each other.
And I don't know
who the boss is.
I'm going to see them in a
couple weeks down in Florida.
And I'm excited to figure out
who turned out as the champ.
But they're really funny,
diving down five feet
to the bottom of a
pool at 11 weeks.
I mean, that's a
shocking thing to see.
And it's just like, I can't
believe this is happening.
But I'm really happy
they're in there.
Here's a behind the scenes
shot taken with a GoPro,
I think a HERO3 Black Edition.
And you'll just see
the quality, which
I think you see the details.
But you're kind of missing
some the illumination.
A lot of people
think I would shoot--
even all these Instagram
GoPro accounts, they always
tag my pictures, GoPro, GoPro.
And I'm like, I
didn't use a GoPro.
Stop doing that.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: But this
is taken with a GoPro.
You can kind of see the
process of me underwater.
I'm in a wetsuit just because
I'm in the water so much.
And if you're in--
anybody a diver out there?
Yeah, Andy, you're a diver.
So I mean, if you're
in water for-- say,
if you're in 80 degree
water for 10 hours,
you know, we're 98.6 degrees,
unless you've got a fever
or you're an alien.
But generally, you're
going to be 98.6 degrees.
And if you're in the water
for a long period of time,
your core temperature
will drop over time
and you will get hypothermia.
And it affects everything.
So sometimes I'm in
the pool for 14 hours.
Even if it's 85
degrees, you'd be
surprised how chilly you
get without a wetsuit.
So I wear a wetsuit.
And I'm also working with the
dogs at such close proximity
where you're going to get
scratched up because they're
trying to say hello to you.
So I do wear that.
But you'll see me
underwater here.
I'm just going
under with a ball.
And then here's the
same moment, almost.
Some of the shots with
underwater puppies you'll see
tennis balls or toys,
some of which you won't.
Sometimes the tennis
ball falls out of frame.
Like here it's in the frame
and then it's drifting down.
It's sinking down below.
And here's a shot.
The illumination, I think,
really comes into play here.
You know, you couldn't have--
if all the shots in the book
were like this, I think it
would be a little boring.
The moment's cool.
But it's nice to be able to see
the details and the puppy teeth
and everything like that.
This is one of my
favorite shots though.
This is not a dog.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: This
is a baby, actually.
And I'm more of a dog guy,
and then cats, and then
like 100 other creatures,
and then maybe babies.
And my publisher
right now is going
to watch this and get mad at me.
But I've been working with
babies for the last four
or five months.
I've photographed 750
human babies underwater
in all kinds of states and
especially the big four,
which are California,
Arizona, Texas, and Florida.
I did an assignment for
"New York Times Magazine"
called "Little
Nemos, Highlighting
the Importance of Water
Safety for Children."
Drowning is the number one cause
of accidental death in children
under five in the United States.
Between 500 and 700
children under five
drown, mostly in swimming
pools, mostly because there
hasn't been proper
safety measures.
And also, the children are
not prepared for the water.
Again, it's another serious
issue that can be prevented.
I thought, you know what?
If I can bring my camera into
this and try to tell a story
and highlight some awareness
about the importance of water
safety for children, I'm OK.
I'm not doing a
book tour for this.
I have no idea if any
books are going to sell.
But if we can improve
the awareness,
I think it's terrific,
even though I'm not a dad.
I don't know if
I'll ever be a dad.
But I did have an
amazing time working
with these little
creatures all around.
But I'll tell you, at the
end of each photo shoot,
I wasn't trying to bring
one of them home with me.
I'm happy to go
home and see my dog.
But it was very inspiring
to watch these babies learn
such important life
survival lessons.
And a range of intensity--
some of the programs
were more basic.
Some of them were very intense.
But either way, it was
very, very productive
and very important.
We have a lot of
media lined up that's
going to promote
this next spring.
The book will be out in
April of 2015, more or less.
So that's what I've been doing.
That's bubbles and paws.
What is that?
Anybody know?
Who can tell me?
Where's a guess?
Anybody know what that is?
AUDIENCE: A tiger.
SETH CASTEEL: It's a tiger.
So I have worked with
some exotic creatures.
This guy's pretty fun.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: So I'm
working on a project called
Underwater Creatures.
I may or may not make
a book out of it.
I'm interested in
photographing types
of animals you wouldn't
necessarily see underwater
but still have a
connection with the water.
Whether or not I
could make a book,
that's yet to be seen
with my publisher.
So I'd like to.
Little Brown, hey.
Let's get a book deal
on the horizon, huh?
But I'm really
fascinated with bringing
the message of helping
other types of animals
through photography.
It's funny and
shocking just what
a photograph can do
these days, especially
because of the internet.
You know, can bring a
message with a photograph
and you can touch a million
people or 100 million people.
Or now something like
over a billion people
have seen the
"Underwater Puppies"
pictures in the
last three weeks.
That's a lot of people.
But when you can
attach something
that's positive about
it and important,
I think it goes further.
I mean, I love the that
the images are joyful
and they make people smile.
But it's cool to bring
a message to it also.
So I'd like to be able to
highlight all kinds of animals
other than dogs and cats and
figure out how we can help them
too by creating some really
interesting images of them
underwater.
We'll find out.
Working with wild animals or
in captivity or in the wild
is always a hot topic.
I've done it on both sides.
I've work with
animals in sanctuaries
to help raise money
for those animals.
I've also done it in the wild.
I've been criticized for both.
So it's a tricky world.
You know, when I'm
photographing dogs at the pool,
nobody really questions it.
But if you're in Alaska
photographing a bear that
happens to come upon you, and
don't see him and you take
a picture, some people are
going to not like that.
So it's tough.
But my intentions are good.
I would like to make the book.
I think it can make some
kind of a difference
for a lot of other
types of animals too.
Anybody have any questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a
dog that likes water.
But he keeps his
head above water.
How do you get them to
dive down like that?
Sure.
So it's all based on the
classic game of fetch.
Yeah.
So I basically start.
I show up at the photo shoot.
I meet the dog.
We become pals.
And they have to know that
I'm the cool dude that's
at the pool.
They get familiar with the pool.
It's all about them being
comfortable and trusting.
We start to play fetch.
We move it into the pool.
I have three games
I've designed based
on the game of
fetch for the pool.
One's called Bobbing for Apples.
The dog comes onto the
stairs or the ramp.
I take the tennis
ball two inches
under, three inches
under, five inches under.
And they start to put their nose
in. and then up to their eyes,
and then deeper.
Once they figure that game
out, we play swim and bob.
They basically swim with me.
And I do the same thing.
They're swimming around with me.
And I have the ball.
We're all swimming out there.
And then I let the ball go.
As a ball starts to sink,
they go under and I dive in.
And I'm taking the
shots with them.
And then of course
the diving game-- one
of my most outstanding
underwater dogs
is dog named Rex, a boxer.
I'll dive down to the bottom
of the pool, nine feet.
I'll hold his rocket
toy up like this.
I'll wave it at him.
And I'm down there.
He'll see it.
And he'll do a full swan
dive, dive all the way down,
swim down at me.
And I'm taking the pictures
as he's coming down.
I hand him the rocket.
He grabs the rocket.
Now we're both on the
floor of the pool, right?
And I've got my weight belt
on to hold myself down there.
He doesn't have a weight belt.
He just dived own.
This dog is like a mermaid.
I mean, it's crazy.
So he's looking at me now.
He's got the rocket.
And he's just thinking, what
are you doing down here, guy?
So then he looks up.
And we're deep.
He looks up like this.
And then he uses his hind legs
and he shoots off the bottom
back up to the top again.
It's the craziest thing
I think I've ever seen.
But the pictures
are pretty cool.
Yeah, I was so excited
to meet this dog,
I get two speeding tickets
in 40 minutes driving out
to Lake Havasu City.
I would have went to jail.
The second cop was
like-- I was like, I just
got-- you know, how is
this happening again?
And I'm like, officer,
is there a problem?
This is the second cop.
Is there a problem?
And he's like, oh,
yeah, you were speeding.
I'm like, no, there
must be a mistake.
I just got pulled
over for speeding.
[LAUGHTER]
SETH CASTEEL: I didn't say that.
He didn't know about
the first ticket.
I would have gone
to jail for that.
I mean, I'm like, listen man.
I just-- there's this dog
that I'm supposed to meet.
He's really cool.
And I was just excited about it.
And he's like, what?
What?
There's something
wrong with you, man.
Get out of here.
But it was worth it, I think.
I got out there finally
and did the shots.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
You seem to keep
revisiting dogs.
Is that because you're
re-shooting, or just
because you're checking
in, hanging out with them?
SETH CASTEEL: Well, dogs
are my number one, yeah.
You mean, why do I keep working
with dogs over and over again?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SETH CASTEEL: That's my--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like you seem
to go back to the same dogs.
SETH CASTEEL: Oh,
visit the same dogs?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Like you've seen them when
they're a year and a half.
SETH CASTEEL: I
have my favorites.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SETH CASTEEL: I
have my favorites.
I mean, I always meet dogs too.
But there's some
dogs like Buster
I like to see from time to
time, Lulu the Jack Russell
and Nevada the border collie.
I mean, I have some
of my favorites,
Rhoda the diving Dachshund.
These dogs have been such
a big part of my life
because they've changed my life.
So when I have an opportunity
to go back and see them again,
it's like the favorite thing
I could ever do, you know?
I mean, they're like my family.
So I like to go back
and swim with them
and take some more pictures.
And it's kind of fun.
AUDIENCE: So what's the
mechanics of the actual shoot?
Do you hold your
breath for a long time?
How do you deal with
your hands holding
the camera, your
strobes, so forth?
SETH CASTEEL: Sure.
AUDIENCE: How does at work out?
SETH CASTEEL: So
I'm in a wetsuit.
I'm holding my breath only.
A lot of people would
think that I'm a diver.
I've actually never been diving.
I'm not even certified to
dive, which is embarrassing
considering how much money I
have in underwater camera gear.
And I love the ocean and
I love sea creatures,
so I do plan to get certified.
But yeah, I've
never been diving.
Actually, if I was
using dive gear,
it would get in the way
of what I'm trying to do.
Some of the photo
shoots, it's more simple.
I don't have to
move a whole lot.
Some of the photo shoots,
I mean, if you're there,
I'm zipping all over the place.
So I'm diving down.
I'm bouncing from side to side.
I'm swimming pretty
fast through the water.
And that would
just weigh me down.
I mean, some of
these dogs are fast.
I've got the ball.
They want it, you know?
And I need to move pretty
quickly so I can set up
the right opportunity
to take the picture.
So I'm in a wetsuit.
I'm just holding my breath.
I go under.
Sometimes I wear a
mask, but most the time,
I just open my eyes
and that's about it.
I have my Ikelite underwater
housing set up with a 5D
Mark III, a Cannon 8 to
15 fisheye, the L lens.
And I had two DS161 strobes.
I hold my camera usually
with my right hand.
And I have the tennis
ball with my left hand.
So I'm just shooting
through the water.
And I'll move it forward.
It weighs about
40 pounds on land.
Underwater, it's not going
to weigh quite as much.
But I shoot through the water.
And I always use this hand for
the tennis ball or the toy.
And I use this hand
to hold onto that.
And I just kind of
had to practice.
But I'm moving fast, you know?
Most of the images that you're
going to see in both books
are taken within about
12 inches of the camera.
And some of the dogs
are diving in fast.
So I got to be very careful
with how I'm moving that gear.
But if you photograph several
thousand dogs and log thousands
of hours in the pool, you
get the hang of it though.
AUDIENCE: Have any of the dogs
ever broken any of your gear,
being that close?
SETH CASTEEL: You know
the answer to that.
Yeah, I've lost a few
cameras over the years .
It's all part of the fun though.
It's all part of the fun.
Yeah, I've had a dog actually
smash through my port, my lens
port, this do named Cowboy.
And yeah, what a rascal.
But he was totally fine.
He just wanted the ball and
he just went for it too far
and just punched right through,
totally fine, the camera
not so much.
It's amazing how fast-- if
you take a glass that's empty
and you put it in
the water, watch
how fast it fills with water.
So he punched a clear
hole in this thing,
and it's blub, blub,
blub, blub, blub.
I had another dog in--
where was I? --San Diego.
And I was just not paying
attention that close.
And I'm supposed to lock on
the port onto my housing.
You can put these
port locks on there.
But sometimes it's a hassle.
So I basically just put it on.
You twist it on.
Now, if you twist it
off, it'll pop off
and your whole thing will flood.
So this dog was reaching
across with his little paw.
And he grabbed the port and
he pulled it 90 degrees,
just ripped the whole thing off.
And that was a 5D
Mark III in there.
That's not a fun bill.
I'm supposed to get insurance,
but I haven't done that yet.
I don't think anybody would
actually insure me anyway.
They're all like, no, forget it.
Cool.
MALE SPEAKER: Alll right,
well, if we could all
please thank Seth
for talking to us.
[APPLAUSE]